and uh next is eric marter he's the
executive director of the integrity of
life that i'm sure all of you are
familiar with
and honored to have him
and
always yours
i'm being wired
thank you walter um
and good afternoon my name is eric mata
i'm the executive director of
encyclopedia and i would like to start
by
thanking the organizers of the symposium
for having me here
share with you our dreams our goals
and to have the opportunity to learn
from our colleagues who are giving these
interesting presentations
also i would like to start by thanking
the macarthur foundation and the sloan
foundation for for their support for the
first five years of the encyclopedia of
life
which has been has been extended uh
one more year for macarthur and two more
years for
from the sloan foundation
the encyclopedia of life
was born as a concept i would say eight
or nine years ago when people started
speculating scientists mainly about the
importance of delivering
information making it available to the
general public
to teachers to students
to other scientists as well
and this was the consequence of the of
the convergence of technologies internet
multimedia
lots of information that had not been
digitized but could have been digitized
and edward wilson was probably the main
evangelist of the concept
which five years ago finally
became a project called the encyclopedia
of life
with five cornerstone institutions
supporting it in addition to the
macarthur foundation and sloan
they are the smithsonian institution
harvard university
the marine mbl the marine biological lab
at woods hall
the missouri botanical garden and the
field museum but of course pretty soon
it became very obvious
that it should be a global initiative
hopefully multilingual
and that it should include global
partners uh as well
so the mission of the encyclopedia of
life has not changed the title of this
presentation summarizes it it is to
raise awareness and understanding of
living nature
of course we do this through a digital
resource an encyclopedia of life
which is free
openly available
highly accessible
and untrusted
we we started with this concept about
five years ago at the time i was at the
national biodiversity institute of costa
rica where i worked for about 15 years
and we had our own version of a small
costa rican encyclopedia of life we
didn't call it that way
but since two years ago we have tried to
take the encyclopedia of life to a new
level
basically by making sure it's a global
initiative that has more partners
and that has a governance model that
includes the participation of of all of
our global partners
but what does it mean to raise awareness
and understanding of living life living
life or sorry living nature or by
diversity is it really is really complex
one way of paraphrasing this and here
i'm i'm going to be borrowing a term
that rodrigo gamez
from the national
diversity of institute coin
it is bio-literacy what we want is to
have every citizen in on the planet
to be bio-literate
this means that they should be aware of
the value of biodiversity
and more importantly they should be very
proud
of what they do to conserve it it's not
easy but we want every citizen to have a
green dimension if if you wish
but living nature
has many dimensions
what does it mean to to be aware of it
and to understand it well first of all
it's beautiful and this is probably the
the easiest dimension to
to use
to convince people that it's worth
studying it and it's worth conserving it
all cultures have displayed this
appreciation for the beauty of of nature
and of living nature in particular
there's a there's a natural biofilia
that we all have
and that in many cases unfortunately
through uh our educational system
uh it vanishes
we want to rescue that
living nature is also very diverse
we want people to be aware of that by
the word about that diversity and also
to understand it better
there's a lot of debate on how many
species that are really on the planet
a more or less accepted estimate is 10
million species not counting of course
microorganisms
but only a few of them have been
identified named and properly described
because there are millions of species
there are potentially billions or
trillions of relationships amongst those
species
so this complexity is is a big challenge
and here is where we expect scientists
to really help us
um decipher the complexity
most of the information is unknown we
want people to know that and and we
should make them very aware of the fact
that in some cases we are even losing
biodiversity that has not been described
in my my country in costa rica
there are hundreds of thousands of
insects alone
and 80 percent of them don't have a name
they haven't been described
even larger numbers can be used to
describe what happens in colombia and in
general in the neotropics
and finally
living nature is indispensable for our
own quality of life and for our own
survival and it works the other way as
well of course we are the main agent
of
uh the main threat let's put it that way
to biodiversity the big challenge the
big umbrella here of course
is that we would like to support
uh the conservation of biodiversity
but this is this is huge this involves
governments this involves ngos this
involves communities this involves
scientists general public and so on so
out of this
more or less accepted now approach to
conserving biodiversity that says in
order to conserve biodiversity we have
to make sure we understand it
we use it sustainably and as a result we
will be able to save it
we focus on the understanding part
we want to make sure
that
us
with respect to beauty we learn to enjoy
it
with respect to diversity we understand
it better
we can help decipher the complexity of
living nature
and we can help unveil
that big unknown that still remains
and as as a result of course
we should be able to enjoy services and
to
be more capable of of
making intelligent decisions to save
uh biodiversity
so one way of summarizing what is it
that that we have with encyclopedia of
life
every word here has a heavy weight and
we could spend some time talking about
each of these but i'll try to be brief
we wanted to be free
if you want to use encyclopedia of life
you go to our website
www.eol.org
and you immediately have access to all
the information
if if you want to participate to write
up comments and so on you have to
generate an account and and that's
something that takes one minute you can
even use your facebook or google account
to avoid you know memorizing too many
passwords and so on
and from then on you are one of our
members
it should be accessible it should be
trusted
this is very difficult because of course
there's
there's a balance there's a trade-off
between having large amounts of
uh information and have good quality
information steve just made the case for
having large amounts of information that
are statistically representative so that
we can infer
scientifically reliable coherent
results
to make things harder and the
encyclopedia of life should be
multilingual by default it started being
a an english language encyclopedia of
life
but since last year we have a spanish
language version
and also an arabic language version the
library of alexandria has been
fundamental in making it happen
and institutions like connabio in mexico
india and costa rica have made it
possible to have rich content in in
spanish however
the main content is still in english we
would have to wait for an automated
process to really turn those
more than a million species pages that
so far have been developed in english
into other
versions of of the the content
it should be built globally the process
through which we
integrate that information is not that
we started from scratch writing up
species pages
many countries many organizations have
already developed their own
and what we focus is on importing those
databases we have established standard
formats
unfortunately and this is a
contradiction of terms there are many
standards
so in many cases we have to
do ad hoc procedures in order to
integrate that information but so far we
have been very successful
at
engaging partners worldwide and
therefore
in in a relatively small amount of time
we have been able to integrate taxonomic
and descriptive information for more
than a million
organisms
and of course the scope is taxonomically
all living organisms and geography
creates
all organisms from the planet
that's the
ambitious goal set of goals that we have
we already talked about the why
and i'd like to present always this this
slide because
um it graphically describes what we want
to do
for many years in different cultures in
many places our
human beings have been aware
of the beauty of the complexity
of the importance
of living nature and and in a very
artistic
way that has been displayed
but we want to go from awareness
to understanding
and so this is the new way of describing
that horse
this is the new way of describing that
beautiful frog from from central america
and this is the new way of describing
the national bird of of taiwan
for each of those species we have the
taxonomic information we have the
natural history bibliographic references
we have been working with the
biodiversity heritage library bhl
they have
really
done a monumental work they have
digitized
more than about 40 million pages of
literature literature that describes
species
the magic number i believe is 1923 1924
copyright issues do not apply before
that and so they have focused their
attention on digitizing that information
but with special permissions they have
also been able to digitize uh newer
information hopefully
new descriptions that come out of uh in
in digital format in electronic journals
um will have more open access so there's
going to be a gap for a while for
publications from the 1920s to i would
say 2010s
who is the encyclopedia of life i
told you at the beginning that we
started with five cornerstone
institutions in the u.s
and very soon
um encyclopedia of life started
integrating participants from from all
over the world right now we have 219
content partners
we have more than 90 curators i would
love to say 90 actively engaged curators
i would say about 60 70 percent of them
are actively engaged in vetting the
information that we import from
different organizations
sometimes or quite often i should say
when we import
information from
from an institution
that has curators themselves
we consider that information vetted
that's information that has been
carefully gathered and we are simply
publishing information that has already
been vetted
we we have two ways of participating we
have content partners
about 20 219 of them but we also sign
memoranda of understanding with
organizations that would like to go
beyond
collaborating
by sharing their data
we could develop joint software tools
we could develop joint uh
citizen science activities and so on
some of or the key or the the most
recent international partners are the
atlas of living australia chinese
academy of sciences
naturalis from the netherlands
library of alexandria
zambi from south africa cornavio mexico
india costa rica academia sinica in
taiwan
we have collaborations between taiwan
and china uh both are generating species
pages for encyclopedia of life
a tree in india and the most recent one
this is as fresh as
last week we signed a memorandum of
understanding with the norwegian
biodiversity information center
they will be
implementing a norwegian version of the
encyclopedia of life
and they will have the information both
in
norwegian and in english
and um over the last uh year we
established a new governance model
that includes a council which is an
advisory committee and an executive
committee that includes most of the
organizations on the third bullet here
as well as the original cornerstone
institutions
where are we now um
we crossed the one million page
threshold
in in april of this of this year
i however have to mention here that
our pages are very
heterogeneous in terms of depth
some of those pages are very rich they
have
dozens if not hundreds of pictures
images videos even sounds
some of them
and texts of course bibliographic
references and so on
but some of them have the scientific
name
common name
and hopefully a link to a vhl literature
that has been digitized
for for many scientists that's enough
that's a gateway to other types of
information about that species and
therefore we have preferred to have this
breadth first rather than depth
this is changing and from this year on
we will
start focusing more on providing depth
to our species pages
6
61 000
registered users uh um use our website
we have something new that we deployed
last year with our second version of the
encyclopedia of live in september called
virtual collections virtual collections
are a very simple very straightforward
way
of putting together information
taxonomists have their own way of
putting together information via a
taxonomy unfortunately i cannot say via
the taxonomy but via a taxonomy
there are many taxonomies and and we
provide access to different taxonomies
even for a single species
a virtual collection
allows any user to go and click on
different species pages and say i want
to put this together
if you wish this is my own taxonomy this
this is the group of species that i'm
interested in
what could that be well it could be
birds from my backyard
it could be
we have one very interesting group or
collection called
sea monsters beautiful sea monsters i
should say beautiful sea monsters
taxonomically they don't belong to any
specific group another one is life is
blue
we have more from butterflies we have
birds we have fish and all types of blue
organisms
and we cannot anticipate um what is it
that people want to do with information
how how they want to cluster that
information
so they do it themselves we started with
30 last september and a little over a
year
later
we have 3 300 virtual collections i also
have to say
that not all of these are very rich some
of those virtual collections were
trials people trying to experience
experiment with this new tool and they
created you know animals from my
backyard and it has
five or six only
but some of them are very very exciting
and we couldn't anticipate
that people would be so excited about it
and would be organizing the information
in so many different ways
but that was our main goal to make the
second version of the encyclopedia of
life which was launched last year more
more engaging and we also have the
concept of community
people who
are engaged
have created
the same type of virtual collections or
have the same interests
and the growth in terms of images has
been outstanding we're getting to the
point of having almost 2 million
images we just flickr we import
databases
and we have made it as simple as
possible
to uh to contribute information
if you visit one of our
pages what you will find is that there's
a big sign that says trusted when that
has been vetted by by a taxonomist or by
a scientist
and if if it doesn't have the word
trusted
by default it hasn't been trusted we
don't have an untrusted sign there it
would be
to to
too rough
and i had already mentioned that we have
more than 200 content partners i want to
give you a
quick
example
of
what a species page looks like
and i'm going to use the case of the the
great
egret i think is the name in english
so we always we have several tabs there
first one is an overview it summarizes
um some interesting stuff about the
species and then we have the details the
details include a distribution
a descript description of the
distribution of the species morphology
natural history
habitat bibliographic references
images in this case this is very rich we
have
i can get a bit more than 100 images and
videos
you see the trusted sign there that has
been vetted by our provider or our
specialist
we started only with maps provided by
gbf we now have maps from nature serve
and other initiatives and very soon we
expect to have a map of life
maps integrated which will take us to a
new level
because so far it has been really shy
our approach to including geospatial
information
common names in different languages
uh what communities to what communities
this species belong and to what
collections what collections include
this species
and if you want to know more about it
look at our partnered links and you can
spend the rest of the day or the rest of
the weekend navigating through those
references
and
learning more about biodiversity and
being more aware of its importance
one point i want to
to make is
particularly important for the education
uh audience
and also for museums
and
schools
we we
believe that eol provides a strong
digital platform to support public
engagement in biodiversity conservation
and very quickly i wanted to make sure
we cover these these issues i already
talked about virtual collections how we
are streamlining the dissemination of
results from scientific research
and some efforts in the bio-literacy
arena
um
first example of a virtual collection is
one called x-ray vision fish inside out
this was an experimental um
virtual collection we created to support
one exhibit
that the national museum of natural
history of the smithsonian in dc
had started it is called x-ray vision
fish inside out so the virtual
collection includes all the images
that are being displayed in that exhibit
so if you go to the exhibit you can
enjoy a good half an hour good hour but
if you want to get information about
those species you can come to the
encyclopedia of life click
on any of these pictures here and get
the information associated with that
species
you could use a mobile device to
navigate as you walk around
uh frankly i was naive enough to think
that that was probably going to be the
way people use it but people don't don't
like to read when they go to a museum
in the best of cases they go back home
and and they do some additional reading
but realistically speaking this works
for groups a teacher who goes
with his or her uh
class
um
they visit the museum
and then they say they can say okay now
we have homework and your homework is
going to be a b c d and e and you
probably don't remember that but you can
do a like a virtual visit to the exhibit
again if you visit the virtual
collection and and that's one way of
supporting the activities of museums
um this is one we got from my friends at
the ministry of of the environment in
costa rica i told them
could you provide me with the list of
threatened species uh in costa rica each
country normally defines their their own
list iucn has a list scientist has a
list but countries decide really what is
it
that is
endangered in their countries so they
provided us with a list of
names
and we
created the corresponding um the
corresponding virtual collection
that automatically in a way we can
interpret this as automatically
generating a website for the ministry of
the environment
that contains the information about
endangered or threatened species from
from that particular country now the
first thing they they told us was well i
don't remember exactly the number and i
cannot see it very well here
say we have really 400 and this
collection only has 200
and of course we said well we only have
200 in the collection because we don't
have
the species pages for those 400.
could you help us develop the species
the remaining 200 species pages
fortunately these that we have here and
are in spanish because embio from costa
rica is contributing with content in
spanish
otherwise
we would have it in english or arab or
chinese
but then that motivated them to start
developing those remaining species pages
the marginal
effort they have to make
to have this quote unquote website is
very small compared to what they would
have had to do
if they had started from from scratch
we would like to see that you know in
every country ministries of the
environment do the same thing the
platform is there we just have to make
sure that the information is also there
the way to put it together we also have
this is another this is not a temporary
exhibit this is a a
a permanent exhibit about mammals and
the natural history museum this is
another exhibit these are pictures these
are not species pages but pictures
um
mary my diversity beautiful sea monsters
i mentioned before
recently extinct animals dodo the
daughter bird is there of course this is
another
interesting way of putting together the
information
and the other example i have here it's
very hard to read
it's birds of dc
what makes it important is not
that
that it's the birds of dc
dc doesn't have a very rich biodiversity
in general
but it is that this was the first
collection that includes
high naturalist observations
we
up until that moment we have not dealt
with specimen level information
observations or uh voucher uh
specimens it's a summary we're
aggregators of information we pro from
gbev for example where they have
hundreds of millions of specimen
level data we get distribution maps
that's basically what we get from gbev
but uh thanks to the work that that eye
naturalist is doing
we are now also integrating observations
not because we want to do that type of
work but because that information is
available and if you want to look at the
details you can go to the i naturalist
website
very quickly
as a way of anticipating
the type of work that
um i'm sorry that
bhl
has been doing
we have established uh sorry agreements
with um pensoft
so that from each of their publications
like
zookeys and fido keys
every time a publication
is published
it's automatically
transformed or turned into species page
of eol
that makes us
hope
that those remaining 8 million species
that have to be described if they are
described under this type of platforms
then they will automatically
be included in the encyclopedia of life
so we are not going to run into the
problem that bhl currently is helping us
solve and with zoltax and we are doing
the same thing
a couple of minutes walter
sure okay citizen science um we we have
pro developed materials
i would call it maybe a teacher's corner
with podcasts with tools
with introductory materials
for children and for
to support k-12 education
but more recently we developed this
partnership with eye naturalist night
naturalist has been very good with
um citizen science activities they have
their own website which is here this one
that i'm showing here
but they have something called projects
projects such as the ones described here
are ways of putting together
observations
because of their geographic scope or
because of the interest that people have
on a specific subject
and that is very similar to the concept
of virtual collections
so uh we now have synchronized the
creation of of projects those that have
an eol
brand in there
those are projects of i naturalists
which in turn are also encyclopedia of
life virtual collections so as people
make observations and put those
observations in one project those
observations become part of the
distribution map that is displayed in
the corresponding
virtual collection this is
a particular project
called birds in north american cities
at the inaturalist site
and this is the corresponding virtual
collection uh
in in eol with the very same map
appearing
in the in the description
and we took it one step further
by um developing a mobile application
for eye naturalist that makes it simpler
you download a virtual collection to
your mobile device from the encyclopedia
of life you go to
that national park to that place you
take pictures
you add those pictures to to the virtual
collection the virtual collection is
like a checklist that you use
during your
day of activities of observations there
and if right there you have access to
internet you can download that and it
goes at the same time
to
to the inaturalist website and becomes
part of that project
and that also goes into the virtual
collection and reaches the virtual
collection
i mentioned that we have content in
spanish arabic language and english
last july
the chinese academy of sciences
inaugurated a mandarin
version of the encyclopedia of life
and that means the interface and the
content or
content
is available in those languages
but there's an interesting in case you
are
planning on developing a project
that has a global dimension there's an
interesting place called translate wiki
where you can have communities of
volunteers help you translate normally
interfaces of software that you have
developed
and we have catalan we have
italian we have french we have german we
have 12 different interfaces or 10
different languages for which the
interface has been
localized
and they include
of course english arabic language
this was quite a challenge because the
menus
you know are on the right and you you re
right to left
espanol
german
french
i want to finish up with two two ideas
here
this is
for the month of basically the month of
of maine
some statistics about visits and i want
you to just look at the map
most of the visitors come from from the
u.s it used to be very focused on the
u.s
now there's a little bit of green in
canada in brazil in costa rica mexico
peru
and in europe and parts of asia
but the interesting thing is really to
me
that when you look at
amount of time spent on the website
average amount of time
the u.s is no longer number one
number one is china number two indonesia
three greece for spain bulgaria portugal
colombia iran ecuador finland brazil
mexico sweden etc etc the u.s is number
15.
now there's there's a
level of novelty that is important here
it's only very recently that we have a
spanish version and that we have
versions in other languages
we don't have a greek version and we
don't have uh
a portuguese version
so
the positive way for me to interpret
this is on the one hand that still the
amount of time the average amount of
time is low
but
that there's there's a market there
there's a need
that initiatives such as the
encyclopedia of life should meet
that's where we are but where are we
going um
there are three key issues
that summarize
the strategic direction we are following
one is and i mentioned this before that
rather than focusing on quantity now we
feel we have enough quantity and now we
can focus more on quality giving more
depth to the information we have a list
called the
the hot list it consists of 75 around 70
000 species
those are highly demanded
we have species pages for each of them
but we want to have very rich species
pages for all of them
and we are about halfway we have them
all but we don't have them all at the
very rich species
content level
we have another even smaller list called
the red hot list
that's about 2500 and we have them very
rich content in english
which we would like to translate to
other other languages
computable data very hard very hard
something that
we all would like to have
one way of describing that is
we would like to have our content which
is very coarsely coarsely structured
into more structured data
so that data mining can be is more
easily done
right now it's natural language
processing that would have to be used to
really interpret and extract for example
geospatial information out of that prose
that describes
the distribution of a species for
example
the sloan foundation is supporting us
for two years
with a small very limited scope
pilot project to do this and
of course i mentioned that our approach
to presenting geospatial information has
been very timid uh we were relying on
gps data and what now
it's only very recently that we are
in importing information from different
sources
that
that is a challenge and that's something
we need to provide
users with
so hopefully by doing these three
main new activities
we will be able to provide our
general public our users
with an opportunity to enjoy
the beauty of
living nature
to understand the diversity
decipher the complexity
unveil the unknown
and better understand that it's
indispensable
and that we should do something about
conserving it
thank you very much
thanks a lot eric
we should probably move it along but
stick around for one quick question and
in the meantime could ben already come
up
so
good question
questions wrong
i just wonder if there's going to be a
dynamic
component to this let's say you've got a
climate change in some areas that
suddenly changes
the species distribution
does that get into the
into your
database somehow
there are two ways that that would get
into the
database uh one is if
our provider
for other power providers
makes a change and we regularly import
according to
to availability of information
we agree
so if they update that automatically
that's going to be updated on the
previous page because we
another way is if you have an account
uh as a curator
you can make the update
go there and update the information to
write a comment
and that would be part of the thesis
page description
so
yes it can be done